Many years ago,
the great British explorer,
George Mallory,
who was to die on Mt.
Everest was asked,
why did he want to climb it?
You said,
because it is their whole spaces date
and we're going to climb it,
and the moon and the planets are they
new hopes for knowledge and piece of
data and therefore as
we have gone on the most as it is in
danger,
greatest adventure,
which man has ever inbox
I to know.
Look at this time.
Don't
just remember those kings will always be
there to guide you.
Okay?
There's a team lean in the spine that
capturing the voice of think sensation
as if a distant memory of forming of a
great height.
We know you're approaching the brand of
this business.
Oh,
books.
Stories written before space travel,
but about space cop.
Could there have been stories about
space travel before the writers,
Chris said made it up.
What does she do
you
want?
What do you want?
You want the moon?
Just say the word and I'll pull it down.
Hey,
that's pretty good idea.
I'll give you the bull,
right?
Oh Man.